Good morning, everyone. And switching over to another rare disease, Waldenstrom. So just
be talking about the novel approaches for Waldenstrom that are happening right in front
of our eyes right now. Here are my disclosures. And just the outline of my talk is going to
cover the current treatment landscape for Waldenstrom. We'll look at some of the emerging
therapeutic options and then also igniting a conversation around anti-BCMA therapies
in Waldenstrom. So as we all know, Waldenstrom has shared similarities on a genomic level
with other indolent B-cell lymphomas as well as multiple myeloma. So all the therapies
that have been studied in Waldenstrom are either lymphoma therapies or multiple myeloma
therapies. And these are some of the trials that have looked at treatment in the upfront
setting of Waldenstrom. And as Dr. Sharosek in a couple of days showed us in her slides
that when it comes to treating Waldenstrom in the upfront setting, we either use BT
inhibitors or chemoimmunotherapy. Those are the mainstay of our treatment.
But there are many other options available as well. When we look at some of the options that
have been studied in the relapsed refractory setting for Waldenstrom, venetoclax was like,
you know, one of the therapies that have been looked into. So we know that BCL2 is overexpressed
in Waldenstrom cells as well. So there was a phase two trial out of Dana-Farber that enrolled 30
patients who got venetoclax. And it worked for majority of the patients, like about 80% of the
patients had a major response. And these response were long lasting. The median PFS on this trial was
two and a half years. Then also at the same time, we had data on pertobrutinib, which is a non-covalent
PTK inhibitor. And the advantage of pertobrutinib is that it works even after patients have like,
you know, progressed on xanabrutinib or ibrutinib. So the Bruin trial enrolled around 78 patients
who had Waldenstrom. And again, we saw something similar to what we saw with venetoclax that
majority of these patients responded to pertobrutinib. And like, you know,
the one thing also unique here is that the toxicities were quite
low compared to what we see with the other BTK inhibitors. And then like, you know, a few years
ago at ASH, we had heard about like CAR-T cell therapy in Waldenstrom. So there was a CD20 CAR-T
candidate from Mustang Bio that like, you know, showed that CAR-T was given to these six patients
and three out of those six patients had deep responses. And there was a trial that was going
to happen and enroll more Waldenstrom patients, but it looks like it's been terminated since.
Then other therapies that hold a lot of promise in
Waldenstrom are the BTK degraders. So they work differently than BTK inhibitors. And I think we
have heard a lot about BTK degraders in the last few days, including the pipeline review from B1,
but just to like quickly recap that BTK degraders are where the BTK is ubiquitinated and destroyed.
So it's not constitutionally active. So we have two different BTK degrader
candidates that actually have trials going on in Waldenstrom. One is from B1 and the other one is
from Neurics Pharmaceuticals. And both of these trials have enrolled a small number of patients
and show that almost everybody's responding when BTK degraders are being used after like,
you know, that refractoriness or resistance to BTK inhibitors.
And then like, you know, talking a little bit now about BCMA in Waldenstrom. So in the last
few years, we have had a few studies that have showed that BCMA expression is also seen in plasma
cells and these mature B cells present in lymphoplasma-cytic lymphomas. And, you know,
there are also studies that have looked at serum BCMA levels that in Waldenstrom patients,
serum BCMA levels are usually three to four times the BCMA level seen in normal healthy controls.
So I think that also opens up another avenue for treatment in Waldenstrom that some of these BCMA
therapies, just like how some of the other myeloma therapies like Vulcade have worked
in Waldenstrom, maybe there is a role for anti-BCMA therapies here as well.
And I think the next slide is what I'm going to show one of our own experiences of a patient who
had MYD88 wild-type Waldenstrom and essentially like, you know, started treatment just like how
our other patients do with a BTK inhibitor and had hyperviscosity at the time of the diagnosis,
required plasma exchange, got Xanabrutinib, did not respond, then got chemotherapy and through
this time continued to need plasma exchange from time to time. And then basically went through each
and every therapy that was available, including Pyrotabrutinib, Venetoclax, some Vulcade-based regimen, and
including Daratumumab, but like, you know, none of these treatments brought on any durable responses.
And then ultimately, like, you know, the thought came of what, like using one of the bispecific
antibodies out there. And because we are a myeloma doctor, we decided, like, let's use one of the
myeloma bispecifics here. And this patient got Elranatumab, and this was like in August, 2024.
So it's been a year and a half since. The IgM levels were close to 4,000, and they dropped
down to less than 20 within a few months of starting Elra. And this patient's maintained that
response ever since. And like, you know, just the past week, I had a patient with IgM amyloid doses,
where we had initially tried Daracybordy followed by Bendamustin rituximab without a response that
we would like to achieve in an amyloid patient. And when I gave that patient teclistamab, like,
their light chains have, like, dropped from 300 down to 40 just during the ramp up itself of
teclistamab. So I think, like, some of these examples are going to continue to come out in
the near future. And they're going to show that, yeah, these BCMA therapies could also have a big
role in treating Waldenstrom. And I think the game is on in terms of what is the right bispecific
therapy for Waldenstrom, whether those are BCMA therapies or anti-CD20 bispecific therapies.
And just to, like, you know, like, conclude my presentation with a few questions that I
always have in my mind and things that we can improve upon in Waldenstrom. Most of our patients
do very well. But that means that these patients are indefinitely on a BTK inhibitor. And we know
that these BTK inhibitor therapy toxicities could be cumulative. About 30% of the patients will stop
BTK inhibitor because of intolerance. And even, like, you know, side effects like atrial fibrillation,
these are cumulative risks that will continue to build upon or happen even after many years of
therapy. And then also we know that some of these patients who are MYD88 wild type or TP53 mutated,
which is usually the bianelic deletions, like, those are patients who don't respond very long
with BTK inhibitor. And at the same time, like, you know, other things that we think about is,
like, when patients do relapse or progress, like, we do have trials, but we really don't have any,
like, you know, phase three trials in the space, unless you consider the INOVAID-WM trial, which
looked at ibrutinib to be a phase three trial in the relapse refractory setting. And then I think
the concept of MRD, which is well established in many other hematologic diseases, is still relatively
new one, because most of our patients don't get into that deep response. But with some of these
newer therapies coming out here, I think this is going to be, again, a topic of, like, you know,
like, hot conversation around whether our patients could be MRD negative and could they be, like,
you know, could they just receive a definite duration of treatment, achieve MRD negativity,
and continue to have a long, durable response. And just to, like, you know,
like, mention here also that this is a very exciting time in Waldenstrom, because all the
newest advances in the lymphoma world and myeloma world are actually coming into clinical trials in
Waldenstrom. And this is a table that covers most of the Waldenstrom trials that are going
on right now, including a trial with mozonertizumab and pertobrutinib that's
actually opening at our site in the next few months. Thank you for listening.